what's up guys bang bang this is the
overview of what happened in the bitcoin
market over the last week let's jump
right in first bitcoin's been trading
around 36 000 or so there's a lot of
volatility across asset classes but
bitcoin actually holding up pretty well
compared to the rest of the market if we
then go look at the actual bitcoin
network stats themselves what we'll find
is that bitcoin is about a 700 billion
dollar asset the inflation rate
unchanged still at 1.77
over 90 percent of bitcoin has already
been issued and is in the current
circulating supply as we look at the
real exchange volume you can see 5.71
billion dollars trading every 24 hours
that mining reward value that means that
miners were paid 33 million over the
last 24 hours to help secure the most
decentralized secure computing network
in the world the gbtc premium has turned
to a discount it's at negative 33
percent bitcoin still almost 50 down
from its all-time high but it's up about
9 or so from the local cycle low if we
then go ahead and we take a look and
compare some of these asset classes it
gets kind of nasty over the last year
bitcoin is down 36 percent the s p 500
is also negative at negative two percent
gold holding strong at plus five percent
but if you go to any other time period
two through ten years bitcoin absolutely
destroying the returns of both gold and
the s p 500. if we then take a look at
what exactly is going on with the
bitcoin price we see here that the
bitcoin price has only been above this
level for 400 days if you bought bitcoin
91 of the time of its life and held till
today you're still in the money but if
you happen to buy it in the 8.2 percent
of the days where it was actually higher
than today you're underwater so
naturally paying attention to that stat
continues to be important then let's go
ahead and take a look at the
side-by-side comparison of each one of
these assets we've got bitcoin gold the
s p 500 nasdaq and tlt we see that the
10-year compound annual growth rate
still 142 for bitcoin drastically
outperforming any of the other assets if
we then take a look at the five-year
sharp ratio we see that bitcoin coming
in at over 1.5 still making it an
attractive asset to put into any
portfolio especially if you're looking
for non-correlated assets bitcoin
continues to be the apex predator of
financial markets from that regard now
let's go ahead and take a look will
clemente and the blockwear team putting
together a fantastic breakdown of
various statistics throughout this past
week i highly suggest that you go
subscribe to their email first we have
here looking at all sorts of value
momentum frameworks as wilma team points
out bitcoin had a really volatile week
but of course if we start to look at
some of the underlying metrics it tells
a very interesting story
first we have the 180 weekly exponential
hole moving average this essentially is
a moving average that weights the
factors to recent price action it just
turned red for only the fourth time in
bitcoin history meaning the moving
average is actually declining rather
than increasing another indicator that
they've been looking at for a long time
now is the short-term holder cost basis
or realized price that currently sits
somewhere around 46 900
bear markets typically involve multiple
failed underside retests of that price
point and so what we see is that once
again it went ahead it tested that short
term holder cost basis and it rejected
it right off of the trend line if we
then go ahead and we take a look the
blockwear team still views the 30 000
mark or somewhere in that low 30
thousands as the place where likely we
will see some sort of reset and visit
that area that is based on a bunch of
on-chain macro oscillators all saying
it's likely to re-test somewhere in that
low 30 000 range the correlation of the
nasdaq remains extremely high as market
participants put bitcoin in with tech
and all their other risk-on assets
then if we take a look at the dxy we see
that that's pushing towards multi-year
highs and bitcoin has seen a sharp
inverse correlation to that dollar index
so let's then jump into the network
statistics all of those continued to
decline unfortunately it's showing a
decrease in speculative retail and
exuberance in the market
then we jump to the actual transfer
volume dominated by transactions below
10 000 and that's also seen a perpetual
decline again will and the team pointing
out that this indicates a transaction
batching by exchanges paired with a
primary decrease in bull market retail
market participants then lastly let's
jump and look at the long-term holder
dynamics what we can see here is despite
that macro backdrop under the surface
crypto natives are still holding on
tight the amount of supply hasn't moved
in at least one year continues to grind
to new all-time highs and the long-term
holder supply is also increasing which
is very interesting when compared to
their cost basis
the rate of decline in long-term holder
cost basis is the sharpest by far in
bitcoin's history and when it's paired
with an increase in the holdings it
shows a level of adoption from top
buyers to long-term holders
now as we continue to look at various
metrics will and the blockwear team
continue to do a great job at all the
on-chain derivative analysis but
ultimately if you just look at the
sentiment as well you can see it all
over the market stocks commodities real
estate bitcoin and crypto at large
everyone is super super bearish and so i
tend to think that the fear is actually
overstated
people need to be aware they need to be
prepared but i don't think that stocks
or crypto bitcoin real estate or
commodities go down forever
i tend to think that at the all-time
highs people get over exuberant they
actually get over their skis and they
think that we're going up forever the
same thing happens when we get into the
bottom of these markets as well people
start to get really really fearful they
start throwing out all kinds of crazy
numbers they think we'll visit but
ultimately what ends up happening is
that we bottom well before the most
fearful believe
and so ultimately what you have to do is
ask yourself am i a trader am i trying
to time markets or am i simply trying to
dollar cost average into great assets
regardless of what the financial market
is
and ultimately what we've seen in the
low cost indexing in stocks or in real
estate and even in bitcoin it's usually
the people that just dollar cost average
into assets have a really long time
horizon they don't try to outsmart the
market by day trading and they simply
don't care about short-term price
movements they tend to just end up
performing better over those long time
horizons and so ask yourself who are you
but one thing i would still suggest
regardless of whether you're a long-term
investor or you're a day trader paying
attention to these metrics is important
the on-chain metrics tell us a whole
bunch of stuff about what's happening in
the market and of course when there's
fear uncertainty and chaos and financial
markets the more information you have
usually the better informed you are and
that can be a really great way to calm
your nerves calm down breathe and relax
because ultimately information ends up
driving patience and patience is what a
lot of people could use right now
i hope that you enjoy these overviews
this past week was a real volatile one
i'll talk to you next saturday and
hopefully we'll have better news but
until then i hope that you guys have a
great week